no school this morning for clark county
school district students all of ccsd out
of the classroom until next wednesday
it's all because of a rise in covet
cases and thus staff shortages but ccsd
right now is saying this is only
temporary hector mohan joining us live
hector the big question is how do we
move forward what is the district doing
to avoid another one of these causes
well the district says they're trying to
do everything they can they're
encouraging testing and soon they'll be
paying a pandemic retention bonus for
employees this morning we're at the
spring valley bus yard where you can see
things are quiet right now with classes
cancelled and some 300 000 clark county
school district students are out of
class until next wednesday due to a
surge in coronavirus cases during last
night's school board meeting trustees
allocated at least 66 million dollars to
pay employees a pandemic retention bonus
that means full-time employees will get
a check of up to two thousand dollars
one way to try and keep the teachers as
the district deals with a staff shortage
and trustees yesterday reminded parents
this pause on classes is only temporary
our goal is to stay open and not shift
to distance education so i know a lot of
families are worried that this is a sign
but we are committed to trying to stay
open and i wish it could be a better
situation for everyone involved right
now
the teachers are still working today and
tuesday just not in the classroom they
have been told to plan from home we
should also note that during last
night's meeting we saw a more cohesive
board trying to work together unlike
previous contention contentious meetings
we've seen before reporting live this
morning hector mejia live local now